تهمتان تلاحق الكاكائين الاولى بسبب كونهم
اكرادا والثانيه هي انها ديانه يعتبرها
الكثير من المتشددين دين كفر اضافه الى
الدوري الايراني الكبير في تشجيع
الميليشيات المواليه لها للتصدي الى
الكاكائين خوفا من امتدادهم في ايران
2006 كان هناك استقرار امني وبدات بعد ذلك
الانفجارات وبدا نشاط القاعده والبعثين
القدماء وبدات معها عمليات القتل
والاغتيال والتفجيرات والاختطاف
والتهديدات وكان الاختطاف يجتهد في
الاغنياء وبالذات الكاكائيون منهم لذلك لم
تعد الحركه متاحه للعمل وبدا الخوف في
الرعب يدبه بين العوائل ولان المنطقه تشمل
اكثريه كرديه والذين يتعرض للظلم
والاضطهاد وتم الاستيلاء على اراضيهم زمن
النظام السابق لذلك نشاناهم من العدائي
بين المكونات في المنطقه
التي يوجد فيها الكاكائيون
لا يجدون القراءه والكتابه هذه مناطق لا
توجد فيها جامعات او مول كبيره ومن يحكم
هذه المناطق اما القائم مقام او مدير
الناحيه واذا كان مدير ناحيه طائفيه ماذا
تفعل فمثلا المحاكم في هذه المناطق تستمع
الى من يملك القوه والصوت الاعلى
لاننا اكراد وهذه المجموعات تنثر من
الناحيه القوميه وفي الاكراد نحن
الكاكائيين الحلقه الاضعف ولذلك يمكن
استهدافنا بالسهوله ونحن نعرف ان جيراننا
ومن حولنا يعرفون اننا غير مسلمين لذلك
المجموعات الارهابيه بدات تستهدف الحلقه
الاضعف من الاكراد وهم نحن الكاكائيون
هي شكلها
وتحرق بساتينهم ويقتل اطفالهم في المناطق
الواقعه جنوب مدينه كركوك لا الحشد الشعبي
ولا الحكومه الكرديه ولا حكومه بغداد
يتجاوبون معنا ابدا نحن في هذا الوقت
مسلوبه حقوقنا كاكرادنا ولكوننا ككائيينه
سيطرتهم على الاوضاع وكانوا يدورون دوائر
الدوله في كركوك وفي معظم المناطق
المتنازع عليها ولكن بعد السادس عشر من
اكتوبر وسيطره الحكومه العراقيه عليها
وقدوم الميليشيات المنفلته وغير الخاضعه
للقانون لهذه المناطق اصبح الاكراد هدفا
لهم يعني
[موسيقى]
الاعتراف الدستوري بوجودنا وان ياتي هذا
الاعتراف من الاعلى من كومه بغداد وان
يكون الكيكه ايون من ضمن القائمه التي
تشمل كل المكونات والاديان ويحق لنا العيش
هنا في كردستان
تتعاقب الحكومه وتختلف سياساتها تجاه
الطوائف الدينيه المختلفه التي تتميز بها
المنطقه ليبقى الكاكائيون يواجهون مصيرا
مجهولا وتضل ثقافتهم وتقاليدهم الضاربه في
التاريخ تواجه تحديات وتهديدات قد تساهم
في تلاشها كليا